what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and we just got our first full official
trailer for Spider-Man across the
spider-verse and it was epic we got so
many different Spider-Man variants in
this trailer including a spider horse
who is actually the character Widow from
the comics yes the spider horse is a
real character they are bringing so many
variants into this movie plus making new
variants it looks like but the big
kicker of this trailer is well for one
we know the plot of this movie now we
know why all of the other Spider-Man
variants are now after Miles Morales we
know that whole plot there but it all
has to do with the Multiverse slash
spider-verse and how it's actually kind
of falling apart right now and how this
is actually connecting to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe as well as other
universes now we've talked about this
before in a few other videos and if
you're a fan of Spider-Man be sure to
subscribe to the channel to stay up to
date on everything happening with the
Sony Spider-Man verse and the MCU and of
course the animated spider-verse as well
well and it does look like they all are
kind of about to collide in a pretty big
way which is the big thing that we want
to talk about today outside of what is
actually happening in this trailer but
of course this trailer references a lot
of things to other different universes
especially when Oscar Isaac's character
Spider-Man 2099 says and don't even get
me started on Doctor Strange and that
little nerd back on Earth 1999 so Earth
one nine nine nine nine nine now right
away some people might be kind of
confused because in Doctor Strange in
the Multiverse of Madness our main MCU
timeline was referred to as Earth 616
however many people have fought this
claiming that this isn't really our
universe we aren't really Earth 616 and
the person who has most famously fought
this is our Miss Marvel Amman vilani in
fact there is a very famous clip of her
stating that we are not earth 616 the
main MCU Universe with our classic
Avengers and everybody is not earth 616
but is in fact Earth 1999 nine nine I'd
like to say that's 616. I don't believe
that the MCU 616 as much as Kevin feige
can make us think that it's 616. it is
one nine nine nine nine nine now we are
unsure of what the future is going to
hold but since we are now in the
Multiverse Saga of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe I'm sure at some point in time
the names or identifications of each
universe will indeed be addressed also
keep in mind that our Mr Fantastic are
Reed Richards the smartest man alive has
not yet been introduced into the MCU at
least not in our main MCU Universe
whether that's earth616 or
1999.99 I think Reed Richards might be
able to tell us but evidence does Point
towards our Earth being 1999.99 because
Spider-Man 2099 is referencing the
events from Spider-Man no way home where
Doctor Strange did his spell with Peter
Parker who was referred to as the nerd
here and essentially broke the
Multiverse and that is exactly what
Spider-Man 2099 is trying to do you in
this movie he's trying to fix the
Multiverse now recently it has been
looking more and more like the Sony
Spider-Man verse is going to indeed
cross over a little bit into the MCU at
least with Spider-Man's story and the
Spider-Man characters that is and
basically the way Sony and Marvel
Studios have been playing nice with each
other it's definitely believed that the
events of the MCU do affect the events
of the spider-verse unfortunately not
really the other way around though so to
put it simplistically the events of the
MCU affect the Sony spiderverse the
events of the Sony spiderverse do not
affect the MCU it's one-sided at least
four now because as we know Avengers
Secret Wars is not that far away
hopefully fingers crossed it doesn't get
delayed but we know that other
Spider-Man variants are going to be
showing up we know that a lot of
variants are going to be showing up and
what's interesting is that the next into
the spider-verse film is going to be
beyond the spider-verse and many people
are thinking that since the title is
beyond that maybe Sony's plan is is
actually to make it live action meaning
live action is going beyond the
animation of into the spider-verse and
there have been some theories out there
some of mine included that this could
possibly be how we get our live action
Miles Morales into the MCU we do know
that universes are going to start
colliding or incurring as they call it
in the MCU and we don't really know what
the end result is going to be we don't
know if everything's just going to go
back to normal or if some remnants of
some universes are going to be left in
other universes and perhaps some
universes that collided will remain that
way this could be how we get Miles
Morales into the MCU as well as some
other characters possibly like the X-Men
that would certainly explain how we
haven't heard of any mutants at all in
the MCU so far so these movies the into
the spider-verse films could be a lot
more important than you think especially
with them referencing the MCU in the
trailers now I really love how this
trailer starts off because it gives us
pretty much classic Spider-Man plots
that we haven't seen kind of in a while
with Spider-Man films in the beginning
of the trailer it starts off with Miles
Morales narrating stating that he's
Miles Morales and he is the one and only
Spider-Man in Brooklyn they say this
because it's kind of foreshadowing the
events of this movie where they're about
to show us just a ton of different
Spider-Man variants you can tell a
little bit of time has gone by since the
events of Spider-Man into the
spider-verse Miles Morales is Spider-Man
full time and is dealing with the
classic things that typical Spider-Man
have to deal with like not getting his
identity revealed especially to his
parents while also trying to juggle
crime fighting and school at the same
time and you can tell that it's very
hard for him to do he's kind of
disrespecting his parents here saying
whatever and you can tell that he
instantly regrets it and realizes what
he has done his mother starts freaking
out saying whatever and his father's
just like wow but this is a classic
Spider-Man struggle which is why it is
so great because the reality is he is
just simply overwhelmed at this moment
he's trying to be there for his family
but in this moment he's also trying to
fight crime and this further goes into
when they're meeting with somebody at
his school a teacher a principal whoever
but they're going over his grades while
at the same time he is trying to fight
who is going to be the main villain of
this film the spot so he's fighting the
spot and he shows up late to the meeting
with his parents the person says that
his grades for physics are good but his
grades for Spanish aren't so good he got
a B and since he has part Spanish on his
mother's side they start to kind of
freak out and make fun of the situation
which is pretty funny even his dad says
Whoa okay are you trying to kill your
mother and his mother is even speaking
Spanish to him because again he's part
Spanish he knows Spanish but his mother
obviously thinks he should know a lot
more than he actually does because he
got to be in Spanish but at the same
time you can see that his spider senses
start tingling that's because the spot
is still out there so he has to leave he
has to bail on this meeting and of
course then the counselor the principal
whoever this is says you know he's lying
to you and his parents kind of know that
this is true you can tell they know and
this is probably foreshadowing the fact
that they are going to eventually find
out that miles is Spider-Man it could be
tragically we see his father hanging
from a high place I don't think they'll
actually kill his father I think Miles
will probably save him his uncle died in
the first film Prowler so I don't really
think that they'll do another death in
his family at least I hope not so then
of course we get Gwen showing up out of
a multi-dimensional portal this is what
we saw in the teaser before and she
brings Miles Morales to the hub
basically a neutral point where you can
access different universes throughout
the spider-verse and Miles learns that
there is essentially a spider society
which is basically what he says it's an
elite crew with different Spider-Man
variants on it they show us a few
different characters who are on it
Jessica Drew we can tell that she is
pregnant like she is in the comics we
see spider Punk who has really really
cool animation when he plays his guitar
also note that spider Gwen her suit is
pretty much exactly the same except for
her shoes she is wearing Chuck Taylors
and actually they are given to her by
spider Punk so no more ballet shoes for
her she has the chuck tailors which are
going to play into the relationship with
Miles and Gwen in this movie obviously
they like each other and they've already
described this movie as a love story
between the two of them but since miles
will see the fact that she's wearing
these Chuck Taylors given to her by
spider Punk he's gonna get kind of
jealous and he's gonna wonder if
anything is going on there between them
then we see Spider-Man India and this is
a cool kind of little Marvel Cameo here
because this is played by Karen Sony who
is the actor who plays dopinder in the
Deadpool movies and they did just
confirm that he will indeed be returning
for Deadpool 3. so we have some actors
in This who have played other parts in
the MCU or in the fox Universe like
Oscar Isaac is clearly referring to the
MC when he refers to the events of that
nerd and Doctor Strange and of course he
plays Moon Knight in the MCU as well so
it's kind of meta there and I wonder if
they might even make a joke about that
then they introduce us to Miguel O'Hara
Spider-Man 2099 he was in the
post-credits scene for the first into
the spider-verse film Gwen tells us that
this whole thing was his idea so he put
all of this together and he is kind of
the leader of the Lobby so Gwen takes
miles to go see him and he asks what can
I do to join the spider team but Miguel
says no there's no way you're joining
this team this is because of the events
from the first into the spider-verse
film that affected the Multiverse
basically the whole event that happened
with Kingpin and the tampering of the
Multiverse made it really hard for
Spider-Man 2099 since his main goal
right now is to fix the Multiverse
because it's kind of broken then he
elaborates on this a little bit more by
stating don't even get me started on
Doctor Strange and the nerd kid from
Earth
1999.99 this is because they of course
broke the Multiverse as well in
Spider-Man 2099 his main goal is to fix
it so anytime somebody tampers with the
Multiverse this directly affects him and
what he is trying to do and this is
where it actually gets pretty
interesting because clearly the events
of Spider-Man no way home have directly
affected what is happening in across the
spider-verse and what Miguel O'Hara is
trying to do to fix the Multiverse so if
the events of no way home affect the
events of across the spider-verse we can
assume that the events of movies like
The Kang Dynasty and what Kang is doing
and Secret Wars are also going to affect
the Multiverse in across the
spider-verse and then in beyond the
spider-verse as well because like I said
it does really seem like the line
between Sony spider-verse and the MCU is
kind of starting to dissolve a little
bit and the Multiverse kind of accident
that happened in no way home affected
both the MCU and now we find out the
spider-verse as well so if events in the
MCU are affecting the spider-verse it's
only logical to think that other
multiversal events in the MCU will
continue to affect the spider-verse so
basically anything that Kang is doing to
mess up the Multiverse at least one
variant of King that is we assume this
will affect the spider-verse and this
will tie into the events of Secret Wars
because we know that many different
variants of many different characters
are going to show up to try and fight
King well if the spider verse is being
affected by Kang we can assume that
they'll want to join the fight and
hopefully this leads to live action
Spider-Man 2099 Miles Morales maybe
spider pug and other awesome variants as
well hopefully spider Gwen fingers
crossed so I do think Kang Dynasty and
Secret Wars are going to affect what is
happening in the universe and universes
that take place in these into the
spider-verse films now back when miles
and spider Gwen are meeting with Miguel
O'Hara we see Peter B Parker from the
first film show up and he now has a baby
Mayday Parker at the end of into the
spider-verse he went back and met with
Mary Jane and this is their baby and she
is web slinging around which is really
awesome and you can see that he made her
a little web Slinger that is also kind
of like a baby toy super cool super
creative love that they're including
this and you can even see later on down
the road in the trailer Peter B Parker
is chasing after Miles Morales and you
can see that he has made a Parker on him
and it looks like she even has a little
Spider-Man beanie on her or a Spider-Man
suit that's been knitted for her now
ultimately it looks like Miguel O'Hara
somehow shows Miles Morales some choices
that he is going to have to make as
Spider-Man like making the decision of
letting seen a family member died to
save a lot more people and he doesn't
think that he can make this decision and
throughout the trailer he tries to argue
with Miguel stating that why can't he do
both why can't he save his family
members and also save other people and
they refer to Uncle Ben stating that if
Uncle Ben had been saved they would have
never become Spider-Man so some things
are simply necessary but we see miles
argue I can be different I don't have to
be like everybody else I can do it my
own way and obviously this does not sit
well with Spider-Man 2099 and he says
that he can't let him leave now another
reason why he can't let him leave is
because the spot was in his universe and
the spot the main villain is another
being affecting the Multiverse which
Spider-Man 2099 is trying to fix so
since miles doesn't really understand
the sacrifices that he has to make he's
only going to get in his way so he
doesn't want him going back to his own
Universe to try and fight the spot
because Spider-Man 2099 wants to take
care of it himself but of course miles
runs away because he wants to do things
himself and he doesn't want to his
family members to die unfortunately this
pisses off Miguel O'Hara Spider-Man 2099
and like I said he is the leader of the
lobby and the spider Society so he
pretty much puts a hit on Miles Morales
telling literally every single
Spider-Man variant that is in the lobby
to stop him Miles Morales is pretty much
John Wick and they have marked him
excommunicado and everyone is out to get
him now but I love how we get the
classic Spider-Man pointing meme but we
get it basically times like a thousand
with every Spider-Man variant pointing
to each other overall this movie looks
like it is going to be pretty fantastic
and I do like the fact that it does seem
to be connecting to events that are
happening in the MCU I think fans are
really going to like it if that happens
it's clearly evident already that events
from the MCU do affect the spider-verse
but that's our breakdown and theory if
you have any theories of your own be
sure to leave them in the comments down
below again please like the video and
don't forget to subscribe so you can
stay up to date on all the latest
Spider-Man news you can also follow us
on Instagram on Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof
foreign